こんにちははじめしゃちょーです
俺は今
久しぶりにちょっとこう
カチンときた事がありまして
ちょっとそれを今日は皆さんにお話しさせて
いただこうと思います
珍しいっすよ
普段あんなに温厚で優しいと
言われているはじめしゃちょーが怒るって
よっぽどのことですからねぇ～
(ドン)
まあ許しますけどそれでもやっぱり
許せなかったんで
ちょっと今回はそいつについて
今日は語らせていただこうと思います
結構近場で起きた事なんですけども
あの、僕よく行くめちゃくちゃ近くにコンビニがあるんですよ
めちゃくちゃ近いんで僕よくそのコンビニ
使わせていただくんですけれども～
やっぱりその何度も何度も
毎日毎日行っていると
その店員さんとのちょっとなんか
まあ仲良くなってるって訳ではないんですよ
別にそんな僕なんか馴れ合いとかしたくないですしね
全然馴れ合いとかはしたくないんですけど
まあそれなりに顔をやっぱ覚えてくるわけです
僕もああいう店員さんがいる
向こうもああいうお客さんが良く来る
っていうのをもう分かって来てるんですけど～
もう僕～あの～そんな全然世間話とかしたい方じゃ無いんですよ
なんかよく使うからこそあんまりそういう話を
したくないというか
もう店員さんとお客さんの関係
それ以上なんかそういう世間話とかもしたいような
関係性を築きたくないと思っておりまして
もう何か話しかけられても俺は
って来ても
…そうですね
みたいな感じちょっと冷たい感じ
かもしれないんで申し訳ないんですけど
あんまりその距離感を縮めたくない
良い距離感でずっといたいタイプ
の店員さんとお客さんの状態を俺保ちたかったんですけど
その店員さんというのがちょっと主婦の方というか
まあ女性の方なんですけれども
なんかある日突然～
今まで全然そういう会話したことなかったのに
「あの、娘がちょっとファンで、娘がファンで
良かったらサイン頂けますでしょうか」
みたいなことを言われたんですよ
まぁまぁまぁまぁまぁ！
それでもしその人の子供が喜ぶのであったら
僕はもう喜んで書きたいと思って書いたんですよ
まあこれは全然僕は良いですよ
全然良いです
僕はそれは全然良いと思うんですよ
まぁお店からしたらどうかは知りませんけどねぇ！
お店からしたら
お金をいただいている業務中に
そういうことをしていいのかどうか
っていうのは会社的にしたら…僕分かんないですけど
まあ僕は全然それは…書きますと
全然良いですよ！って言って
こうやってレジでこうやってサイン書かせていただいたんですけれども～
まあそれはもういいでしょう
良いです、僕も全然良いです、むしろオッケーです
いい人だと思いました
コングラチュレーションでございます
(拍手)
だがぁ！
そこで話が終わっちゃあ俺はこんなに怒っちゃいねぇ
そこからだ！
他の人もなんか
「え、私も～いいですか～」
みたいなその「私もサイン貰っていいですか」
みたいな感じでそのどんどんその連鎖反応みたいなのが
起こりだしてきて
まあ他の方にも僕はその店員さんなどにサインを書くことが増えまして
まぁ！
いいですよ
まぁいいです
全然僕は良いです！書きます！全然書きます！
むしろいつもコンビニでお世話になってるんで
それぐらいの事をさせていただきたいという気持ちが
まぁ…無い事も無かったんで
全然書きますよ！全然書きますけども…
そっからぁ！
そっからがちょっと僕はカチンと来ましたね久しぶりに
まあ凄い良い人そうなんで直接本人には言わないんで
こういう場でもう…言わせていただくんですけどぉ！
面と向かっては怖くてとても言えないです
いい人たちなんで
かといって心の奥にしまっておくのも
ちょっとモヤモヤして嫌だなと思ったんで
今回ここで言わせていただいてるんですけどもぉ！
そのなんか子供にサイン書いた女性の方が…
なんか…
そのなんか1週間後か分かんないですけど
時間なくて急いでて
なんかお昼ご飯をこうやってバタバタ探してる時に
そこにこうやって来て
「あの～すいませ～ん
(城之内はじめ)
ちょっと待ってくれ！
あなたの周りの人のサインなら何でも書くと思ってんの？
って僕だったら思いますけどね
で結局その～ちょっと急いでんのに
レジでお買い物した後に2枚色紙に書かされて
1枚はその宛名があったんですよ
ちゃんと誰かに渡すっていうのが分かったんですけど
もう1枚に関しては
みたいな
( ﾟДﾟ)ﾊｧ?
オイ待てよ！
渡す人がいるから俺は色紙書いてんじゃないの⁉
渡す人がいないのに色紙を書く意味！！
何！
もう俺それ聞いた瞬間めっちゃなんかイラっとして
なんで渡す人いないのに色紙俺書いてるのって思いました
誰かにあげたいから色紙書かされてると僕思ってる訳でしょ
これ名前無いんだったら～
ストック用で、なんか誰かに
「あ～はじめしゃちょーにサイン貰ったよ～あげる～」
みたいなパターンか、
もうメルカリとかでそういう何かオークションとかで転売するか
のもう2択しか僕には見えなくなって
そのお姉さんが俺は凄いなんか怖く感じましたね
お店で働いてる人として
そういうのを何度も何度もするのは
僕は良くないと思います
素直に
まぁお店からするとね
なんなの！いいよ別に！言われりゃぁ書くよ俺だって
サイン何枚でもさぁ！
まあ時間なかったら書かないんですけど
サインなんて書くけどさぁ！
「名前なしでいいです」ってどういう事！？
転売したいの⁉
転売だよねぇ！
それが何！？
誰かに！いい顔したいから！取っとくの俺のサイン！？
そういう風に俺は思ったね！
あーもうこういう事言うから
ますますコンビニにも行きづらくなるし！
まあいいんですけど！
ただ俺は！
その人たちとの関係を潰したくないんでｌ
本人に面と向かって言わないんですよ！
ここで！言わせていただいてるだけです！
気にしないでください！
クッソォ！
チクショ―！！！！！
ウワアアアアアアアアア！！！
ウワアアアアアアアアア！！
ウワア↑アアアアアアアア！！！
オエッゲホッ
ウワアアアアアアアアアアア！！！！！！！！！！！
♪CHA-LA HEAD-CHA-LA
いやそういうのじゃないんすよ
そういうのじゃないんすよ！！！
いやそういうのですけどォ！
オイどうしてくれんだよ！
髪の毛の色！変わっちまったじゃねぇかよ！
オイお前のせいだからな！
お前が変な事言うからこんなことになっちゃったんだぞ！
お前ふざけんなよ！お前！オォイ！
マトマ：師匠！駄目です！暴力は駄目です！
お前ふざけんなよ！
ハァ…
クッソォ！！
マ：暴力はダメです！
オラはサインは書くよ！
サインはもちろん時間があれば全然書くけども
時間が無い時はサインは書けねぇんだ
オラも他のみんなと来てるわけだ
サインを書くことで、そのサインを書くのを待っている
仲間たちの時間の事を
考えてやって欲しい！
そして、何度も何度もサインを求めてくるやつは
マジでーよく分かんねぇ
書く本人にサインを書くのは全然いいんだけども～
その本人のなんか知り合いとかのたくさんサイン書かされるのは
オラは許せねぇ！
間接的にオラはサインを渡したくねぇ
ましてやそのサイン書いたところに
「あ、名前はいいです」みたいな名前なしで書かされると
なんか転売とかメルカリに出されそうで
オラはますます許せねぇ！
そういう真似は！
あの、どうか控えて頂けるととてもありがたいと思っております。
すいません、よろしくお願いいたします。
せーの、
かめはめ波！！